مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيد
نفاع
[موسيقى]
حديثنا اليوم عن تعاقدات او صفقات الدوري
السعودي والانديه السعوديه مين لحد الان
هو النادي الافضل على مستوى التعاقدات من
المتوقع انه تعاقدات تكون الافضل على
مستوى الموسم القادم من اللي قدر يختار
افضل اللاعبين حتى الان رغم انه سوق
الانتقالات ما انتهى ورغم انه في بعض فرصه
للانديه لانك تعمل تعاقدات جديده ولانها
تحاول انها تستقطب لاعبين كبار من اوروبا
مثل ما شفنا على مدار الاسابيع الماضي
بدايه خلينا نبدا مع نادي الاتحاد اللي
كان عمل المفاجاه الكبرى بالتعاقد مع كريم
بنزيما وبالتعاقد مع انغولو كانتي اعتقد
انه كريم بنزيما راح يكون هداف الدوري
السعودي على مدار المواسم القادمه لانه
بنزيما جاي وهو بفورم عالي هو بمستوى جيد
نعم في اصابات في نزوله شوي بالمستوى
مقارنه بالمواسم السابقه ولكن بنزيما
بضلوا قيمه كبيره وبضل لاعب جاي مش باخر
مسيرته بمعنى انه باخر موسم او مسيرته
لذلك اعتقد انه صفقه بنزيما هي اقوى صفقه
بين كل التعاقدات اللي عملتها الانديه
السعوديه هذا الموسم صفقه كانتي ايضا صفقه
مهمه رغم التخوف من الاصابات لانه كانت
باخر مواسم كان عرضه للكثير من الاصابات
كان عنده كثير مشاكل على هذا المستوى بس
بضل اذا كان جاهز على مدار الموسم وما
تعرض لكثير اجهاد وتحضر بدنيا بشكل جيد
كانت راح يكون بالتاكيد اضافه كثير كبيره
للدوري السعودي وقد يكون افضل لاعب
للارتكاز على مستوى هاي البطوله اذا كان
بمستواها الطبيعي واذا قدر انه يظله يعني
اسابيع طويله بدون اصابات بالانتقال
للهلال الهلال لابرم تعاقدين ايضا مهمين
جدا كاليدو كوليبالي القادم من تشيلسي
وروبن نيفيس قائد الولف قائد ولفرهامبتون
الصفقتين ايضا جيدين جدا
يعني لاعب وسط جيد هو قادر على انه يسدد
من خارج المنطقه قادر على انه يضبط ايقاع
الملعب قادر انه يحمي الدفاعات ولكن رتبه
بطيء مثلا مقارنه بكانتي مش لاعب البوكس
تو بوكس القادم ان يقدم اضافه بهذا المجال
والهلال بصراحه محتاج للعب وسط ارتكاز
يحمي الدفاع الى حد ما يعطي ثقل اكبر
لمنتصف الميدان ويحاول انه يقدم خبرته
واعتقد انه ما في افضل من روبنفس لهذا
الدور فبالتاكيد صفقه روبس صفقه مهمه جدا
ولكن حسب رايي الشخصي هي لا ترتقي لمستوى
صفقه كانتي لذلك اعتقد انه الاتحاد يتفوق
في هذا المجال اما صفقه خليده كوليبالي
فهي صفقه مهمه جدا شفنا انه الهلال بكاس
العالم للانديه لمواجه ريال مدريد يتقبل
خمسه اهداف شفنا انه دفاع الهلال ما كان
بافضل شكل ممكن هذا الموسم وهذا كان سبب
رئيسي بانه الزعيم ما يحق لقب الدوري
السعودي وبالتالي قدوم لاعب بخبره كاليدو
كوليبالي ان كان بدور الابطال ان كان
بالدور الايطالي مع نابولي او ان كان
بالتجربه القصيره لقضاها بعد تشيلسي
بالدوري الانجليزي
اما الاهلي واللي هو القطب الرابع من
الانديه السعوديه المملوكه لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه فهناك حديث ايضا عن
تعاقد الاهلي او قرب تعاقد الاهلي مع
روبيرتو فيرمينو فيرمينو اللي كنا بنعرف
مغادره ليفربول بعد انتهاء عقده كلاعب
بصفقه حره الان بالنسبه للاهلي متاح
بالسوق وقد يكون اضافه ممتازه جدا لهجوم
الاهلي هل رح يكون على حساب عمر السومه هل
رح يرحل المهاجم السوري بحال قدوم فيرمينو
ولا راح يتم توظيف الاثنين مع بعض هذا امر
متروك للايام بحال قدوم فرمينو مره اخرى
ولكن فيرمينه هو لاعب مختلف تماما عن عمر
السومه عمر السومه هو لاعب المهاجم
التارجتمان اللي بيستهدفوه دائما
بالعرضيات وبيسدد من خارج المنطقه بشكل
جيد وبيسجل عدد كبير من الاهداف على مدار
الموسم فرمينو اكثر هو لاعب فولت لاعب
مساند او مهاجم ثاني داعم للمهاجم الاول
في الفريق لذلك هناك امكانيه وفرضيه
لابقاء اللاعبين معا في نادي الاهلي لحد
الان افضل صفقات موجوده بالسوق هي صفقات
نادي الاتحاد بلا شك والاتحاد يعني اذا
حافظ على هذا القوام الموجود اصلا من موسم
الماضي مع هاي التدعيمات اللي عملها اكيد
راح يكون قادر على تحقيق لقب الدوري
السعودي الموسم المقبل رغم انه مش لازم
نستهين ابدا بالمنافسه الكبيره اللي راح
تكون موجوده من قبل الهلال ولا مصر ولا
الاهلي على مدار الموسم القادم هذا كان كل
شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافره حتى نلتقي
الاسبوع المقبل كونوا بالف خير